[Musique]
l'amant point est un monstre elle
possède une bouche dans tous
voulu cruel et crochus dans la morsure
est aussi implacable que l'étreinte
capitaux et derrière c'est tu suis
obstinée se déroule un étrange corps
serpentiforme est seul aspect inquiétant
son comportement parasites qui remet en
fait une bête chimérique
rarement un animal qui a côtoyé l'homme
depuis la nuit des temps s'est retrouvée
à la fois objet de plaisir et
d'investigation
encore de nos jours qui connaissait
animal ses mystères je connais des
plusieurs personnes du monde de quoi
c'est très très vieux
c'est un poisson à venir et l'on croît
être un poisson sont les patrons les
pêcher avec ses fils et là ces défilés
qui qui grattent le fond voilà c'est dit
il et travail qui rate le fond et qui
dérivent donc cédé dérivant de fond qui
la rend proche de tellement bizarre des
fois on le trouvait elles sont enroulés
sur le lien jelal sur le plan sont à ras
du fonds
à la mer et les grâces la droite dont
beaucoup de nourriture et les plumes se
bonifie à montana le remarquer que ça
n'a pas 50
attention surtout être au bouillon la
sauce soja
qui n'apprécient pas la recette c'est
une grosse et un ctp ni moins et jusqu'à
la vie sur le dos des autres poissons
on la trouve aussi bien nos collections
et de baleines des cachalots sur un
requin
sur un autre petit pont sur une allonge
est arrivé quand on est revenus qui est
le plus gros chez quel os ce point là où
il faut éviter la sorcière passée l'as
vitré ou
au fait revenir au sens sur la dordogne
de décembre à mai on pèche ces étranges
animaux qui en fait ne sont pas du
poisson mais qu'on appelle quand même
comme ça là l'emploi se déguste au
portugal et en angleterre mais ici dans
la région aquitaine
elle fait partie véritablement de la
culture locale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour ce faire aujourd'hui les faits
viennent faire là
[Musique]
non banier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean vanier mai à laval paléontologues
directeur de recherche au cnrs des
recherches en gym t'ont fait découvrir
les ans cet élan trois dans des roches
plus vieille que 500 millions d'années
scellé cette adhésion à travers le coût
de cette lamproie à la bordelaise
accompagné d'un verbe bordeaux et signer
le registre
le match
c'est pas ça
[Musique]
c'est sans doute un bon exemple
puisqu'on a des animaux donc en chine
530 millions d'années environ qui
ressemble vraiment à des landes 3
actuelle enfin au moins au niveau du
plan d'organisation anatomique les
détails c'est évident on n'a pas
exactement la même chose
par exemple une différence fondamentale
c'est la bouche la bouche de la
l'endroit est très particulière
actuellement avec un système de ventouse
dedans corner on n'a absolument pas ça
on n'a pas retrouvé sa dans le cambrien
mais par contre on tout ce qui concerne
les branchies par exemple les arcs
branché os les muscles de l'animal la
forme générale la bouche et même des
organes beaucoup plus difficile à
fossilisés comme le cerveau ou le coeur
on se dit que c'est très très semblable
à la lamproie actuelle
[Applaudissements]
dans la chaîne de l'évolution des
espèces la lamproie n'est encore qu'un
animal au long squelette cartilagineux
est presque déjà invertébrés elle est un
des premiers maillons de l'évolution des
espèces qui donneront les mammifères et
donc les hommes
des centaines de millions d'années plus
tard alors un cerf-volant procès sauf à
tisser patrick rault est tout petit mais
c'est c'est déjà un cerveau un cerveau
de vertébrés c'est déjà un cerveau
complet si je puis dire c'est c'est ce
qui se passe entre les entre les
vertébrés des invertébrés c'est
justement la naissance du cerveau la
naissance de la tête je devrais dire
parce que non seulement il ya un cerveau
qui fait deux véhicules à bord du trois
puis cinq véhicules à l'avant du de la
moelle épinière de la prototype de
moelle épinière
mais en plus il ya un crâne dessus qui
est fait pour le recouvrir pour protéger
ce qui fait que c'est globalement on
appelle ces espèces non pas des
vertébrés mais les crânes yade ce qui
les différencie leurs traits
caractéristiques c'est le crâne
ils ont un crâne puis une tête avec
rassemblant les organes des sens visant
une bouche une bouche très très
spectaculaire sauf justement les
lamproies qui ont probablement perdu
leur bouche dans le cours de l'évolution
séparément de leur groupe soeur qui va
garder la bouche et donner les poissons
les poissons classique avec une grosse
mâchoire
depuis qu'on a découvert son statut de
plus vertébrés la lamproie intéresse les
scientifiques
mais depuis beaucoup plus longtemps les
hommes en remarqué la qualité de sa
chair et ont mis au point des techniques
de pêche efficace en dordogne la lampe
race pêche de deux façons au filet ou à
la bourgogne
c'est à dire la nasse aujourd'hui les
nas sont en plastique les pour martial
et alfred elles sont encore en osier ça
ne coûte rien il n'ya que ça va faire
chaque année et à l'endroit adultes
remonte du fond des océans
animé d'une pulsion migratoire
indispensable à sa reproduction
elle reste en général le jour à cocher
aux cailloux d'où son surnom de suspects
hier elles se déplacent la nuit car elle
déteste la lumière les pêcheurs le
savent bien qu'ils préfèrent venir jeter
leurs filets au milieu de la nuit pour
en capturer davantage sa remontée
ancestrales et est devenu une course
d'obstacles notamment à cause des
barrages hydrauliques et pendant des
dizaines d'années elle s'était fait rare
dans les eaux aquitaine mais ce n'est
plus le cas aujourd'hui
les hommes y s'il apprécie tellement ils
ont décidé de lui faciliter la vie
pour franchir certains ouvrages on a
construit des passes à poissons sorte
d'escalier hydraulique
pas évident a priori que les lampes 3
s'introduisent dans ses goûts les
étroits même si elles sont guidées par
les courants forts qui sont créées au
pied des passes mais ça marche
pourtant comment faire quand la
différence de niveau est vraiment trop
importante on n'hésite pas à employer
les grands moyens
donc ici on se trouve sur le site de
tulle hier où on a à l'ascenseur à
poissons l'ascension à pression c'est
très simple c'est que on piège des
pompiers étaient poissons dans une cuve
qui est relevé par un système de treuil
et qui est déversée de allaman ce qui
permet aux poissons de franchise de
franchir aménagements tout les endroits
où la majorité de l'enfant qui se
présentent aux pieds de tulle hier
parviennent à passer à l'amant de
louanges donc c'est quand même rassurant
a priori donc l'ascenseur aurait une
réelle efficacité
enfin pour l'espèce
il faut savoir qu'en france au moins et
j'ai pas peur de dire en europe aussi on
a très peu de connaissances sur le
comportement des enfants au niveau des
obstacles à la circulation
c'est pour ça qu'il se trouve que en
2005 on arrivait nous deux premières
études sur la dordogne entre cuillère et
me et meauzac à l'aide de marc
magnétique et on a truffé
les dispositifs de franchissement en
particulier face à des scènes de mauzac
d'antennes de réception pour essayer
d'appréhender un petit peu mieux le
comportement de la lamproie au niveau de
cet obstacle
holy de co2 de la marque si les marques
individuelles 7,9 à 943
ça nous permettra de suivre le devenir
de cet élan de foi au long de sa
migration
ces contrôles ont pour vocation de
savoir si l'espèce se porte bien
les comptages montrent que 80 % des
lamproies arrive à passer tous les
obstacles grâce à ces ascenseurs et ses
passes à poissons disséminés sur la
dordogne
on est passé de quelques milliers à
40000 emplois en peu de temps il y à une
véritable explosion de la population des
aménagements sur d'autres bassins au
portugal où sur le rhin ont eu les mêmes
effets bénéfiques si ces investissements
n'avait pas eu lieu
la lamproie risquait de disparaître
comme cela a été le cas pour d'autres
espèces
joli les banques et les doublons
les jours de pluie
marcel et alfred se prépare pour
l'ouverture de cette pêche saisonnière
est règlementée ils fournissent les
mareyeurs et surtout les conserveries
car la lamproie n'est pas facile à
préparer chez soi
[Musique]
chaque hiver donc et l'emploi remonte le
fleuve et marcel d'essence et bourgne
une fois posés au fond du lit labour n'y
crée un repos et offre aussi un refuge à
l'abri du courant la lamproie attiré
fatigué vient s'y reposer ne peut en
ressortir
[Musique]
en
bon
oh
[Musique]
après avoir lutté pour passer les
barrages évitez les pêcheurs mal
intentionnés mis plusieurs mois à
remonter 200 ou 300 km de flotte et de
rivières et cela sans se nourrir et
l'emploi trouve enfin des lieux
favorables pour leur reproduction
une eau peu profonde est clair un
courant rapide des galets et des
graviers de dimensions différentes du
sable fin forme un endroit idéal pour
construire l'avenir
contrairement à d'autres migrateurs
comme ce moment elle ne vient pas se
reproduire sur les lieux de sa naissance
mais on a constaté que la présence de
larves dans les cours d'eau favorise les
frayères
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les mâles arrive quelques jours à
l'avance leur dos montre du fait de leur
maigreur un axe cartilagineux qui leur
tient lieu de colonne vertébrale ils ne
craignent plus la lumière est diffusé à
ce moment là par leurs branchies les
hormones sexuelles des phéromones pour
attirer les femelles
ces faits remontent seront détectés par
celle ci au niveau de leurs naseaux port
ce n'est accessoires petit orifice qui
se trouvent sur leur crâne va commencer
alors avec une farouche énergie la
construction déplaçant les plus gros
caillou avec la bouche qui fait
ventouses en se laissant aller avec le
courant chaque mâle va progressivement
dégagé une cuvette et par des battements
de queue provoqué la suspension puis la
sédimentation du gravier et du sable
le nid ainsi construit peut mesurer
environ un mètre de diamètre et une
vingtaine de centimètres de profondeur
dans cette construction
il est souvent aidés par la femelle
devenu aveugle au cours de la remontée
et qu'elle rejoint ce travail fatigant
épuisant laborieux semble un prélude
indispensable à l'accouplement
mais c'est ainsi quand vient le mois de
mai le certains lits de rivières sont
constellés de tâches peur
soudain le mal se fixe sur la tête de sa
partenaire
apx à ventouse sur sa nuque mort la peau
et perfore la chair de ses dents corner
la femelle ne le cherche pas à se
dégager de cette étreinte douloureuse en
se détachant du caillou auquel elle
adhère
[Musique]
en enroulant son corps en spirale autour
du corps de la femelle
le mâle exerce une pression qui facilite
l'expulsion d'un paquet 2 ceux ci sont
fécondés simultanément par sa semence la
femelle agitent frénétiquement la queue
soulevant un nuage de sable qui vient
enrober les heures recouverts d'une
langue mais j'imagine 2
ceci alors dit tombe alors au fond d'une
y viennent à l'abri des prédateurs ils
auront ainsi de grandes chances de
survie et ce processus explique
certainement en partie la longévité de
l'espèce à travers les temps chaque
accouplements répété plusieurs fois dure
seulement quelques secondes les effets
conjugués de l'épuisement et des toxines
qui en résulte conduisent les lamproies
inexorablement à la mort
laissant les larves issus des oeufs
orpheline enfouis dans le fond de la
rivière pendant six à sept ans cet
accouplement unique signé d'une feinte
mortels marque l'ultime moment de leur
cycle vital
il y a des lamproies dans toutes les
mers du monde
mais de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
elles ont vécu une drôle d'histoire
parce que celle qui remontaient le
saint-laurent et les rivières de la
région pour aller frayer étaient
bloquées par les chutes du niagara et ne
pouvait donc gagner les vastes étendues
des grands lacs jusqu'à ce que les
hommes s'en mêle
[Musique]
trois sont signalées pour la première
fois dans le lac ontario en 1835
comment sont-elles arrivées là on pense
que le canal érié qui fut construit pour
relier le lac ontario à l'océan
atlantique a permis aux lampes droit
d'entrer dans la zone des grands lacs
leur présence signalée un siècle plus
tard dans le lac érié les 1929 a été
possible grâce à la construction du
canal de welland contre le lac ontario
le lac est rien afin de contourner les
chutes du niagara
il y avait eu colonisation graduelle de
tous les grands lacs
on retrouve dès 1938 les lamproies dans
le lac supérieur le plus au nord vingt
ans plus tard la colonisation était
totale mais l'endroit d'un talent hors
la caractéristique de la lamproie marine
c'est de vivre dans la mer et de migrer
en eau douce pour aller se reproduire et
bien là non
ce vertébrés préhistorique a montré une
nouvelle fois sa capacité d'adaptation
il n'est jamais retourné dans l'eau
salée de l'atlantique dès son plus jeune
âge alors que la l'emploi n'est pas
encore adulte elle parasite les
populations autochtones de poissons
truites et corégone sont décimés par ses
millions de bouches voraces
[Applaudissements]
il était évident dès le début que les
lamproies vers un impact sur la pêche
donne et qu'elle tue les poissons sans
leur laissant deux grandes théories de
bien sûr indirectement à travers les
maladies infectieuses qu'elle provoque
est comment avez vous pu mesurer leur
impact sur la crèche les pêche des
poissons à haute valeur commerciale ont
chuté très rapidement après que les
lamproies heures en veille pour les
grands lacs
par exemple dans le lac huron nous
sommes ici en 1936 l'auto neige de pêche
de la truite de lacq poissons de choix
recherché à cette époque chuta de
quelques millions de livres ces quelques
centaines de milliers de livres
cet impact de lembras fut
particulièrement dévastateurs et
provoqua un changement dans la vie des
populations riveraines des grands lacs
affectant les communautés locales qu'ils
vivaient du commerce de la pêche et les
conduisant à cesser leur activité sans
compter les dégâts environnementaux sur
une grande échelle
il est difficile de nos jours
d'apprécier combien leur action fut
dévastatrice pour l'écosystème des
grands bacs dès son implantation dans
les grands lacs
la lamproie marine n'en a plus bougé car
elle a sans doute adoré ce vaste et
milieu poissonneux aux dimensions océane
pour elle les petites rivières sont
devenus des fleuves les petits torrents
des rivières et elle prend les truites
de lacq pour des baleines
à moins qu'elle n'ait jamais retrouvé la
sortie les américains eux détestait
recettes colonisation et les indiens qui
avaient à une certaine époque le
monopole de la pêche les rangs ni
responsable de cette invasion
il fallait agir dans les années 50 les
autorités canadiennes et américaines un
responsable de la pêche et de
l'environnement organisé de chaque côté
de la frontière
une lutte sans merci contre ce parasite
dans les qualités culinaires leur était
inconnu
question de culture peut-être ou de
pollution la première mesure mise en
oeuvre était la construction de 40
barrage sophistiqué mais d'une hauteur
accessible au saumon et autres 8
[Applaudissements]
il faut évidemment
le barrage gonflable s'ouvre comme un
livre
comme si les pages livres des 1ères
balles qui soulèveraient en fait sa
couverture qui dans ce cas est une lame
d'acier un obstacle verticale est ainsi
créé qui bloquent le passage et non
droit nous pouvons régler la hauteur du
barrage
pour cela nous avons un système qui
mesure en amont et en aval le niveau de
l'eau on peut ainsi maintenir une
différence de niveau constante
un peu comme un thermostat réguler la
température dans une maison c'est ici la
station biologique d'amendé c'est à cet
endroit précis que les premières
lamproie envahissant les grands lacs se
retrouver l'ont compris le problème
qu'elle représentait et que les
premières études concernant leur cycle
de vie furent entreprises on savait très
peu de choses sur elle comment ils se
reproduisent et quel était leur cycle de
vie
une grande partie des travaux
scientifiques les concernant a été
réalisée ici c'est aussi ici que fut
développée dans les années 50 un
échantillonnage de quelque 6000
molécules chimiques et que furent
sélectionnés parmi elles au travers de
nombreux tests celle qui était toxique
pour les larmes même si le lan prix seed
n'est destinée qu'aux l'emploi il y as
certainement quelques dégâts collatéraux
quel que soit le produit les effets ne
sont pas toujours favorables à
l'environnement
de plus ce poison mortel n'était pas
adapté à toutes les rivières et la
lampre faisait de la résistance
il fallait trouver autre chose et les
chercheurs d'amendé en réussite
dans ce type de piège nous avons pu
attraper 3500 l'endroit en une seule
nuit
3500 l'emprunt d'un coup dans ce piège
il eût été sans doute éthiquement
incorrect de les éliminés froidement
les chercheurs ont mis au point des
systèmes de capture d'une efficacité à
faire rougir les pêcheurs de la dordogne
le but
la stérilisation des mâles car le
problème de la lamproie séquelles pont
deh e par centaines de milliers pour
stériliser les mâles il faut donc les
capturer juste avant de reproduction et
les trier
mais on
fox email
mais recenseurs mais ans
vimeo
et oh
mais on s'y met
mais ans
ce marquage a été effectuée cette
semaine deux encoches ici et une encoche
là et le modifiant ce marquage chaque
semaine en changeant le nombre
d'encoches que nous réalisons dans la
nageoire
les mal trié séparer des femelles passe
côté américain pour être stérilisés
avant l'opération
l'appartenance au sexe mâle est à
nouveau vérifié
l'histoire ne dit pas ce que sont
devenus les femelles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans un premier temps là l'enfant avait
posé le poids est intégrée dans le
programme informatique de l'auto
injecteur ce programme calcule la dose
de bise à dire les stérilisant chimiques
qui doit être à l'animal après ça invite
est instauré dans la chambre dans
laquelle l'animal est enfilé par nature
des cellules photoélectriques en mesure
la longueur de la langue 3 afin de
déterminer le positionnement de
l'injection un système de crochets
maintien de mal en place les tuiles est
positionné sur la salle endroits précis
où on doit pénétrer la cavité
péritonéale le visage est injectée
points précieux combien de temps les
mâles vont ils rester ici c'est mal le
stériliser reste à l'intérieur pendant
48 heures jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
décontaminé
ils sont déplacés à l'extérieur pendant
72 heures
ramener enfin la rivière saute ça
dommage qu'elles contiennent du mercure
autrement vous pourriez d utiliser des
fins gastronomiques comme l'ont fait en
europe
oui oui j ai souvent pensé mais je n'ai
jamais essayé d'en manger
c'est très bon c'est très bon nous les
cuissons avec du vin de bordeaux de gros
poireaux et nous invitons le son du
poisson vraiment suivant la recette
certains rajoutent le padd du chocolat
c'est très bon c'est en plein recherché
c'est un plat très cher
retour côté canadien émasculé
chimiquement ils sont prêts à être
relâchés sur les lieux de capture et
entrer en compétition avec les autres
mâles entiers comme leur libido est
intacte les femelles ne ferons aucune
différence en conséquence il y aura
moins de l'art et donc diminution
notable de la prolifération des
lamproies mais pour améliorer la capture
et le contrôle les chercheurs sont en
train de mettre au point un système de
voir une expérience sur les phéromones
sexuelles devant un labyrinthe sso bleue
contient est en principe ou des fins
malsaines longtemps que chez certains
êtres vivants l'eau mal aimé des
phéromones de puissantes molécules
sexuelle reconnue par les femelles
l'équipe damon b a réussi à concentrer
isolé puis très récemment à synthétiser
l'une des phéromones de la lamproie
voici venu le temps de tester en milieu
naturel l'action de cette molécule
si ça marche on pourra mettre alors en
place des pièges moins pour lui en plus
efficace
voici différents modes nous la mettons
dans ces 25 litres d'eau là qu'on va
délivrer ce mélange au milieu du piège
un taux constant de concentration la
concentration finale sera très très
faible 150 mètres en aval cinq femelles
munis des moteurs sont placés dans une
cage
[Applaudissements]
santa ya quelquefois les femelles sont
immédiatement quand on ouvre la cage
parfois elles attendent 20 minutes avant
de sortir
hélas suspens vont elles se diriger vers
le piège à phéromones
ad
aujourd'hui quatre femelles sur cinq
sont rentrés dans le piège
malgré ce succès il faudra beaucoup
d'autres tests pour valider l'expérience
en aquitaine les vieux pêcheurs savent
depuis longtemps par empirisme kamal
laissé dans une borne à dire les
femelles par mesure de protection cette
pratique trop efficace est aujourd'hui
interdite sur la dordogne
[Musique]
de noël à l'ascension
alfred et marcel viennent régulièrement
relevé le ranger de bourgain leur
lamproie sont moins stressés est
meilleure que celle pêche au filet
distille mais tirer les câbles tendus en
travers de la rivière à contre-courant
n'est pas de tout repos
personne ne veut le faire à la bourre
n'y à la nasse au filet à la main à la
pince la pêche à la lamproie a traversé
les siècles pour approvisionner le plus
souvent les cuisines des demeures
seigneuriales car soigneusement préparé
la chair de la lamproie et d'une finesse
incomparable
[Musique]
les menace qui pesait sur les
populations de lamproies ont incité les
scientifiques à mieux connaître leur
cycle de vie
longtemps resté mystérieux et leurs
rapports avec les autres populations
piscicoles
c'est dans ce but qu aujourd'hui les
équipe de biologistes du cemagref se
servent de cette technique
d'endormissement fugace régulièrement
ils effectuent ce genre de prélèvements
dans le chevelu du bassin versant de la
garonne surveille méthodiquement les
zones de frayères qui cartographient la
fois l'aquatique est ainsi identifié
répertoriés afin de mieux appréhender
l'écosystème où se développent et lavaud
orpheline
une fois que les yeux mi-clos vienne et
là on en reste sur le nid quelques
encore quelques dizaine de jours voire
quelques semaines avant de gagner des
zones
de de sédiments meubles avec de la
matière organique qui va leur permettre
donc à la fois de s'enfuir donc elles
vont se faire un carnet dans lequel 20
ans logis et qui vont leur permettre de
filtrer l'eau et de se nourrir en même
temps et de se mettre à l'abri des
prédateurs
donc elles vont rester dans ces zones
préférentielles pour un laps de temps
qui va varier les n'estime en moyenne de
l'ordre de 4 4 à 6 ans et celle en
espèces alors ses larves filtre un
filtre l'eau
donc elles se nourrissent
essentiellement de plancton en la
matière pour le moment alors il
m'apprend marine 161 grammes alors la
métamorphose d'une part survient lorsque
la leyre latin et tailles à peu près 15
cm trace pas caractéristique que l'enjeu
pour observer modifications externe chez
l'animal tiennent surtout à l'apparition
de l'oeil qui qui était entier cachée
celle alarme apparition également du
disque brutale avec dédain qui vont
devenir de plus en plus pointues et
également au niveau de la
défendront cian healy transformation qui
va s'opérer et également au niveau du
corps une livrée argentée qui pourraient
être prises
il s'est donc passé entre 5 et 7 ans
entre la ponte la métamorphose après
cette vie sédentaire enterré dans le lit
de la rivière
elle est prête à aller vivre sa vie
d'adulte de la rivière elle va gagner
successivement le fleuve puis l'estuaire
et enfin le grand large océanique
au cours de cette dévalaison elle
grandit son métabolisme se transforme
afin qu'elles soient en mesure de
survivre dans l'eau salée puis qu'on
perd sa trace
des quelques grammes et qu'elle pèse
lorsqu'elle est l'arbre en moins de deux
ans elle va gagner sa taille adulte sa
nourriture va être muscles et 100 des
poissons ou mammifères marins qu'elle
rencontrait sur lesquelles elles se
fixent voracement qu importe la taille
qu importe l'espèce hareng requins
daurade baleines dauphins aloses durant
des heures durant des jours elles s'y
agrippent par une morsure souvent
mortelle qui lui permet de foyers les
muscles et de sucer le sang
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous voulons donc eu lieu sont stockées
et l'on croit ainsi une somme au canon
nous et canadiens de nature c'est la
plus grande collection de l'emploi au
monde en termes de thenon
nous avons à peu près du niveau de
l'emploi et ça fait à peu près 20 milles
de spécimens et puis nous avons aussi
une très grande diversité
37 des 38 espèces de l'emploi sont leur
présenterai dans nos collections il
edou d'australie l'australie lors dacia
précoce cet esprit du collectionneur
alliant passion et constance est aussi
soutenu par une quête de les comprendre
pourquoi pendant la croche de la
lamproie qui peut durer des jours sur
ses victimes non consentante
le sang ne coagule t-il pas quels sont
les facteurs anticoagulant contenue dans
la salive émises par les glandes
salivaires
je retire la peau encore le musc et
ainsi sont exposés les deux langues en
forme darricau ces glandes contiennent
une véritable soupe dans une avec
lesquels les l'emploi plus de gérer les
différents tissus des poissons qu'elle
parasites puisque ses glands sont
entourés de musc ses muscles se
contractent un pouce la soupe dans une
barre la bouche et lorsque la l'emploi
est attaché à aux poissons cette usine
que de gérer l'issue est ainsi se rend
directement au sein du poisson la
lamproie marine se nourrit à 98% de st
il est évident que
mais cette soupe contient des centaines
de produits potentiellement pour avoir
un effet anti kabyle à thouars il se
pourrait que une fois isolé ce ou cette
substance anticoagulante puisse être
utilisé pour par exemple attaquer des
caillots qui bloque les vaisseaux
sanguins
par exemple dans des bars et ses
célèbres de ottawa à bordeaux en passant
par stockholm ou amandes b les
scientifiques s'attache à mieux
comprendre l'animal à maîtriser la
connaissance de son développement
larvaire de son patrimoine génétique à
décrypter ce navet est né son génome
sous le nom générique de petro me zones
marines us sus pierre en grec da
l'emploi est un sujet d'étude plein de
promesses
déjà en europe au siècle des lumières
elle fut inventorié classé dessiner puis
plus tard accompagnant les nouveaux
outils d'investigation comme le
microscope son cerveau se révèle à un
modèle à la fois simple et complexe pour
mieux comprendre l'organisation des
territoires nerveux
c'est ainsi qu'a bien en cette deuxième
moitié du xixème siècle
sigmund freud jeunes scientifiques après
ses premières gammes chez claus et la
recherche sur les testicules des
anguilles à leurs assistants l'institut
de physiologie chez bruch trouva grâce
au cerveau la lamproie la résolution à
l'énigme non encore résolus de la
constitution du système nerveux
oui il est composé de cellules
individuelles dont les prolongements les
axones sont les éléments conducteurs de
l'information nerveuse
si freud a gagné sa célébrité grâce à
d'autres raisons que nous connaissons
l'intérêt de sa découverte n'en fut pas
moins importante pour l'époque
puis il laisse à ses successeurs
l'élucidation de la propagation de
l'information de cellules nerveuses en
cellulaire puisqu'elle unit polarité
avec le mécanicien de rands t
défilent pour
[Musique]
il s'intéresse aux instincts primitifs
au développement de de la psyché de
l'humain et en même temps il a commencé
par se former en étudiant le
développement de ces bêtes très
primitive qui ressemblait qui n'avait
probablement pas besoin de psy canalis
mais qu'avaient déjà ébauchée le système
nerveux qui est quand même le support de
nos instincts de nos émotions et de
notre psychisme d'employés il avait on
dirait que quelque chose dans sa science
a été précurseur des travaux qu'il a
fait par la suite en s'intéressant à ce
qu'il ya de plus évolué dans l'animal
c'est à dire la pensée nos petits fous
plus d'un siècle après les observations
de fruits les scientifiques continuent à
utiliser la lamproie au même titre que
le rat de laboratoire comme un modèle
expérimental qui leur ouvre de nouvelles
perspectives d'investigation
musique on retrouve les même noyau lui
même structure on retrouve chez les
mammifères
ces minus noyau sont plaisants il est
classé avec les mêmes projections on se
trouve avec la même organisation que
dans le système nerveux du mammifère et
sas c'est une beauté c'est phénoménal en
fait et quand on fait l'analyse cette
chute cette bestiole je me suis allé
première fois que j'ai regardé un second
enfant je me dis c'est pas possible
c'est comme un cerveau de chat et puis
mais en miniature
cette organisation là est la même en
fait que celles qu'on retrouve chez les
mammifères voire même langue et en même
temps on a une accessibilité à
l'activité cellulaire qu'on retrouve
très difficilement dans d'autres
préparations humain
en fait à l'aide de micro électrodes de
berre on se positionne au dessus des
cellules qui en fait j'ai à l'emploi
sont géante et on sont facilement
visible à l'aide de la loupe binoculaire
donc il est possible de venir se
positionner au dessus de ces cellules
assez facilement pour qu'on est bien
positionné on rendra à l'intérieur et on
la range de stabilité qui nous intéresse
en fait c'est de voir quels sont les ces
jeux des tuyaux ce final qui sont
activés par la région locomotive
mésencéphale iq a pour ce faire
opposition unie lecteurs de stimulation
directement au niveau du mésencéphale et
aussi les lecteurs de stimulation pour
voir la tige ici qui va être
progressivement descendu à l'intérieur
du mésencéphale peut être localisé
plus précisément dans une région qu'on
appelle la région de côme à tous mais
encéphale alors les lecteurs dès
maintenant en position style la région
locomotive les encéphalique on voit
effectivement cette augmentation
d'activation dans les cellules qui se
traduit par une augmentation de
condamnation de collations rouge
en fait les cellules que nous
enregistrons sondés
neurones les neurones de commandes donc
vous reçoivent l'information qui leur
est acheminée et ses neurones de
commandes envoient l'information vers
des réseaux locaux moteur sans situer
dans la moelle épinière et par la suite
ses neurones de la moelle épinière
on voit le cette commande aux muscles et
de façon alternée qu'est ce qui permet
la nage de l'animal ces observations
nous ont permis raf est de développer
des nouvelles stratégies pour
l'amélioration de des conditions des
patients qui ont obtenu des lésions de
la moelle épinière
alors les travaux qui sont réalisés dans
le domaine fondamental sur la
compréhension des mécanismes et revues
responsable de du contrôle et de la
génèse la locomotion en fait ce sont des
informations qui sont primordiales à au
développement de stratégies ou de bonnes
stratégies sur l'amélioration des
conditions de patients ayant eu subi des
lésions moelle épinière
ces nouvelles stratégies qui dans un
futur assez proche seront bénéfiques à
des patients ayant subi des lésions de
la moelle épinière ou des amputations
des membres sont élaborés plus
particulièrement dans un laboratoire de
chicago chez le professeur moussa ivaldi
ce chercheur a fabriqué un fascinante
hybride une véritable chimère mélange de
vivant et d'électronique
une machine qui perçoit le monde
extérieur et des signaux lumineux les
transmet à un cerveau de lamproies isolé
mais vivant signaux qui une fois intégré
provoque en retour des ordres donnés à
la machine de fuir cette lumière honni
de l'animal
ce que nous faisons nous stimulons ont
des réseaux et nerveux vestimentaire un
côté droit le signal arrivant de l'oeil
droit puis au style on le côté gauche le
signal arrivant de l'oeil gauche
balbutiements et premier pas d'une
science nouvelle la bionique permettra
peut être un jour la mise au point de
prothèses ultra perfectionné à commande
cérébrales direct un dialogue permanent
qui s'institue entre puce circuits
imprimés et microprocesseurs prolongeant
et se substituant à l'action des
neurones l'émergence d'une nouvelle
science est en route
elle ne pourra faire l'économie d'une
réflexion éthique on utilisera de plus
en plus ce genre de modèle pour faire
avancer les progrès et la connaissance
des cerveaux humains si vous commencez à
chercher à comprendre les choses sur cet
univers
comprenez qui est qu'ils quittent d'une
complexité fabuleuse qui est un cerveau
humain vous ne risquez pas de comprendre
au complexe il faut que c'est pour comme
pour le système comme pour les galaxy
c'est comme pour univers il faut
commencer à voir les propriétés les
réduire à un astre voir un peu après les
interactions entre entre deux objets
bien identifiés revient de pouvoir
généraliser et d'être sûr qu'on a une
théorie qui va tout expliquer et cetera
je vous ai écouté il faut il faut
toujours réduire avant de pouvoir
généraliser
dans son laboratoire le cuisinier jean
marie amat 1,6 les lamproies pour
réaliser une lamproie à la bordelaise
la lamproie est le seul poisson qui
exige d'être saignés vivant comme c'est
le cas habituellement pour les
mammifères et les volailles ce qui rend
sa préparation un peu difficile pour nos
sensibilités et les murs de nos cuisines
au moyen-age on la mange étant galantine
c'est à dire en gelée ou en croûte
c'est à dire en pâté mais presque
toujours accompagné d'une sauce noir
confectionné avec son sens cette sauce
lamproie fait partie des grandes
sociétés val et sera servi même sur du
rôti de boeuf
la consommation de l'emploi a toujours
été considérée comme un mets raffiné
réservé aux notables et aux riches et
même si les populations des estuaires
l'ont parfois manger griller la plupart
des recettes exige beaucoup de
préparation et un long temps de mise au
taz
[Musique]
et à l'expérience je me suis rendu
compte que effectivement il y avait une
vraie connivence entre la lamproie le
poireau et le vin est là et ça et et
cette espèce de liaison miraculeuse de
la sauce avec et tout ça c'est vraiment
là une question de chaudron magique
s'apprécie ccc la cuisson qui fait qu'
on arrive avec le mijotage à ce qu'on
arrive à faire ou pas d'ailleurs parce
que c'est les cardinaux au 18 ème jeu
l'étape se ruiner pour bien sûr pas se
retourner parce que parce que c'est ça
ressemblait à du gras en même temps
c'était maigre voilà donc c'était poser
c'est si oui c'était des viandes c'était
des viandes de karen et les premières
salles à une recherche crois qu'ils ont
monté la tamise
on en faisait un peu plus et on le
ferait pourquoi oui il faut dire que
puisque nous faisons un étalage
d'érudition en rien le fait que la tâche
est né et mort empoisonné par une
l'emploi par la date et l'endroit
mais elle est juste au point la lamproie
c'est vrai que c'était accroché aux
traditions tant que nous avons le
souvenir de mer ont fait la lamproie
nous continuerons à faire un point c'est
un peuple à qui te plaît bourgeois c'est
pas un plat de restaurants c'est pas
c'est c'est pour ça que la route il va
bien et le l'enfance ne nécessite pas
l'exégèse le subtil leur arrivée et
pourtant quand on veut un concept adopte
la plaine il en fait une oeuvre d'art
c'est quelqu'un aujourd'hui pied de nez
inattendue que ce raccourci
gastronomique
l'arroseur arrosé en quelque sorte le
vampire saigne à blanc pour aboutir à ce
miroir et des tableaux indéfinissable le
plaisir qu'il nous procure passe sans
aucun doute par des circuits normaux
complexe qui restent à déchiffrer hommes
et l'emploi ont encore un long parcours
commun
en deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]